georgia runoff okay georgia runoff is uh
taking place today yep georgia election
rule today are you flying
runoff races no candidate exits 50
percent
republicans have 50 seats 48 two more
you know
etc etcetera you got two names that are
going off back and forth georgia has not
elected a democratic senator since 1996
24 years is a long time
uh the runoff races come after president
joe biden made history as the first
democrat to win georgia's presidential
race since 1992
nbc news projected they're not even
calling them president you know the
president-elect joe biden because it's
not
done yet you haven't collected your
money yet close to a half a billion
dollars
close to half a billion dollars close to
half a billion dollars has been injected
into
two races as both parties race to secure
slim majority in the state
either to give life to the legislative
hope of a president
like joe biden or stamp them out before
his
term begins a record 3
million voters have already casted their
ballots in the elections
making up 38.8 percent of all registered
voters
in georgia thoughts you know
okay so it's been since 1997 since
georgia has elected a democratic senator
kai what were you saying as far as a
presidential 92 something like that
right
96. you know what okay the reason shifts
or the reason trends like that shift
is when there's a dynamic person to vote
for so there isn't one of those on the
democratic side in georgia right now in
the senate runoff election
so if a democratic candidate wins today
something's up i mean it's just that
simple when you collect three million
ballots in advance the level or the
opportunity to
do bad things with those ballots is is
high and if you just if you just look at
this
objectively stacy abrams you know is a
very very big figure in georgia
collect you know getting votes
collecting these ballots early
there was a court case last week where
they tried to slow down some of this and
the judge said no
i will not slow it down that was stacy
abraham's sister
who was the judge so we all know what's
at stake with this today
um are are the democrats that
sure of themselves that you know
something fishy could happen again
and no one will find out i don't know i
just
i think for the sake of the country
whether a republican or democrat
it helps to have a little bit of balance
in power
and i think for the sake of the country
it's important that purdue
or lafleur one of them wins today it's
that simple
and you know what it's going to get ugly
there's going to be violence no question
about it
you think there's going to be violence
fema actually came out homeland security
actually came out said last week you
know regardless of what happens there's
going to be violence in georgia
you know there is you know dc is bracing
for what's going to happen later this
week with the electoral college vote
in congress tomorrow so it's a volatile
time in our country
it's scary and you know what i i just i
hope one of those republican candidates
win for the sake of the country who do
you think has most uh
more likely to win you know i would have
said purdue probably but he's been in
quarantine since last thursday so he he
was he had some some contact with
somebody that tested positive for covet
so he hasn't been able to campaign
i don't think it matters i think your
mind has been made up a long time ago i
don't think you're going to switch your
mind
and make your decision on who you're
going to vote for in the last three or
four days
uh i like lafayette i like kelly laufer
i really do
i mean you know her husband is the
president of what
new york's new york stock exchange like
i said yesterday she's got a pretty good
consolation prize she's
married to a billionaire even if she
doesn't win i i think one of them is
going to win
i don't trust the polling and yesterday
the polling came out and said that it's
very very close
we learned back in november you know
what kind of stock we can put into these
polling
you know numbers so i think of
republicans going to win i think it'll
probably be loffler
yeah again i haven't really been paying
attention for the last couple weeks
obviously we've known about this for two
months
that this has been the target date since
everything but it's gotten really ugly
in georgia what's the
the one thing i did see in the news
recently was trump made a call to the
republican
secretary of state of georgia trying to
find uh 11 000 votes the guy's like look
dude like
i'm a supporter of you but i'm not about
to do anything and plus he recorded the
conversation
yeah so i think uh carl bernstein who
was one of the watergate uh
writers uh was like yeah this is
straight up worse than watergate like
what are we talking about here he's
calling you know trump has a way of
talking where he's like
look i don't know i'm not telling you
that you should find this but maybe you
can do this
like a very mafia kind of talking right
very interesting what happens there but
back to you where again i haven't been
following
the the news last time i think we spoke
you were at 30
trump was still going to win where are
you at right now
30. you're still there yes damn 30
man okay so at what point are you down
to zero like when biden like
when biden really steps into office no
when he wheels his walker into the oval
office but
at that point you'll say all right like
he's the president like i just wanna
yes i'm being genuine here yes okay yeah
it's not official yet
okay 30 but you're still at 30. yes
where do you think most trump supporters
are at this point
i'm asking legitimate questions here
where are trump supporters there
are they do they still think that he's
got a true true true truth yeah that's
what i'm asking oh i think they're
thinking
this thing still has a chance they still
do a hundred percent i think a lot
gotcha i'm not saying they think it's a
hundred percent yeah
but i think trump supporters believe
there is a chance that this thing could
stop
one of my best friends is like the i
have actually a lot of best friends who
are
very close friends who are huge trump
supporters and they're constantly
texting me like
the one guy that kai you spoke with um
joe
he's like oh it's happening bro it's it
like he'll
randomly it's happening everything i've
been talking about is happening i'm like
what's happening tell me something like
you know what i think a lot of those
like your friend
yeah trump's been too quiet for the last
three weeks what
well i mean other than the call to the
secretary's database other than you know
that whole watergate called
he's played a lot of golf he's but it
makes you think
he has something up his sleeve he don't
got nothing up his sleeve player
i'm not saying it's gonna work i just
think something's up his what's your
number at this point
i mean tom's somehow trump lost
the election and tom's numbers have gone
on but i'm also saying 70
chance that biden is gonna be the
president yeah but you were at 20
or like 15 like two months ago yeah so
but you were at five percent this entire
time
are you still there five percent okay so
bub you know what fi
again i explain to you what five percent
to me is yeah five percent to me is
i'm not gonna make the bet on five
percent but i'm telling you there's a
five percent chance because you don't
know what's going to happen all of a
sudden something could flip
morano just sent a five dollars and said
i hope the democrats win in georgia so
they can rewrite the constitution with
gender neutral pronouns
amen and a woman i heard some guy say
that yeah
ah man and they women i was classy so
but this is a very big day in georgia
like whether kelly lefler or rafael
warnock win
versus david perdue john ossoff um
[Music]
what i'm finding comfort in is the fact
that the people running georgia are
republicans what brian kemp is the
governor of georgia
republican huge trump supporter trump is
like threatening to throw him in jail
because he won't
listen then you got uh what is it
roefesberger or whatever the uh the
secretary of state is that
that was the guy in the call that was
like oh with all due respect mr
president like
you're lost homie like i don't know how
to tell you this but
but trump's like no maybe i didn't lose
he's like yeah
you did sorry you know it's awkward
these phones yeah but that conversation
happens with every presidential
candidate i guarantee you bill clinton
was leaning on people obama leaned on
people
just like every other president hey can
you find me 11 000 votes oh you think
that's like a thing that everyone does
totally
oh i totally do i if you're in politics
you're doing that all right so
here's another question let's say they
find these 11 000 votes oh
that was he's like 5 000 dead people
voted right uh
roethlisberger he's like yeah two
which just goes to show you that he's
full of crap because there's way more
than
two votes i'm just recapping the
conversation none of this is my opinion
okay it's for all the
soy boy haters out there shout out to
the show by mafia
um the um i'm just i heard that
conversation but
um it's
it's interesting to see what's going to
happen here i feel like you got
something to say how does he turn on his
own
how does a how does a republican
secretary of state hand this over to the
world
they believe in america not just trump
is my
assumption i think no i i disagree i
think there's a part of it
where um they believe
in needing their income and keeping
their jobs
you're going there with it it's a very
logical assessment if you're not
emotionally connected to
trump you care about your job the person
that to me it's kind of like very
interesting why he's such a true
believer and he's putting his reputation
on the line is ted cruz
that's the one that's very interesting
to me because he's going out there being
no this is not real he did not lose we
did not lose the election right
he's not backing down he's going to
stand up and he's going to stand up a
very easy answer what is that
i mean and same with josh hall what is
that
it's a very easy answer what is it
inspiration to be president 100
okay in 2024 does he want to be having
trump based being like yeah
ted cruz stuck with us and he was there
when we tried to steal the vote and we
we love you ted
yeah or like well he was honoring
democracy let me ask you a question let
me ask you a question
there is also part of that that he's
taking a bigger risk
the bigger risk is the fact that when
that happens later on
you're you're assuming that all the
republicans are going to be for cruz
and all of trump's is going to win the
election in 2024
if cruz decides to run for president
2024. so there is a risk for cruz as
well there i'm just surprised that he's
doing it it's risk and reward right i
think
i think we're talking about ted cruz now
we're i mean it's gonna
which by the way the base is you know
what you want to say about ted cruz ted
cruz gotta be one of the smartest guys
that you got in america he's a
genius the guy is yeah i don't care what
anybody says that guy's a genius i'm a
fan
yeah you know and i wonder what his
aspirations are i don't know if they are
president you know there's
what do you mean he ran for president in
2016 clearly there's also talking about
him being in the supreme court i mean
there's a lifelong job that you don't
have to campaign for
right so um who knows he could be a
supreme court i saw that conversation
come up about being
him being a supreme court the reality of
it is exciting he's not going away
he's not going away yeah he's he's not
going to weigh in so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye